bonjour Jean-Marc Jancovici merci d'être
dans ce studio pour répondre à mes
questions ce matin vous êtes ingénieur
vous êtes président de ce chiffre projet
que vous êtes aussi l'auteur d'une bande
dessinée x un succès absolu qui ne se
dément pas un véritable best-seller sur
la question justement du du climat de
l'énergie et aussi de l'industrie
puisque vous ne tournez pas le dos à
l'industrie bien au contraire et elle
est au cœur de l'actualité de
l'industrie parce que Emmanuel Macron a
relancé hier l'idée qu'il fallait
réindustrialiser et faire de la France
la première des économies décarbonées
mais je vais d'abord une chose on
n'arrête pas de nous parler de la valeur
électrique le bonus écologiste ne sera
plus donné aux voitures qui ne
répondraient pas à un certain nombre de
normes on va y revenir dans le détail
mais est-ce que la voiture électrique
c'est vraiment l'alpha et l'oméga d'un
passage à un monde écolo alors quand on
parle la voiture électrique à la voiture
à pétrole
elle présente un certain nombre
d'avantages et un certain nombre de
similarités on va commencer par les
similarités ça reste une voiture donc ça
reste un objet de une à deux tonnes du
reste les voitures qui marchent bien
c'est plutôt des voitures de 2 tonnes
que des voitures d'une tonne parce que
les constructeurs font des plus grosses
marches sur les plus gros véhicules et
par ailleurs comme la voiture électrique
vaut cher c'est plutôt les gens à fort
pouvoir d'achat qui poste y mettre donc
une pas un segment important aujourd'hui
du marché de la voiture électrique c'est
les grosses voitures acheter par des
cadres qui veulent se donner bonne
conscience
voilà
mais le donc la voiture électrique reste
une voiture ça veut dire que
ça veut dire qu'en termes d'occupation
d'espace au sol par exemple en termes de
consommation d'espaces au sol ça veut
pas seulement dire la voiture elle-même
ça veut dire les routes ça veut dire les
autoroutes
ça veut dire également que en termes de
consommation de matériaux pour faire la
voiture bah on n'a pas beaucoup de
différence par rapport à une voiture à
pétrole et en fait il en faut même plus
parce qu'il faut fabriquer la batterie
et dans les pollutions il y en a une qui
reste presque constante par rapport à la
voiture à pétrole c'est les poussières
parce que la voiture électrique elle a
aussi des plaquettes de frein des pneus
qui s'usent etc par contre ça présente
des avantages sur le plan du CO2 ça de
façon incontestable parce que il faut
effectivement dépenser plus enfin
émettre plus de CO2 pour fabriquer la
voiture parce que en fait il faut
fabriquer la batterie en plus de la
voiture et en gros les émissions de
fabrication de la batterie aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près les émissions de
fabrication du reste de la voiture mais
par contre à l'usage d'abord le moteur
électrique est beaucoup plus efficace
que le moteur à essence le rendement
d'un moteur électrique c'est à peu près
80% quel que soit le régime moteur alors
que pour un moteur à essence c'est entre
20 et 40%. et ensuite vous avez la
production électrique en France qui est
très très nettement décarbonée par
rapport en France oui mais même même
dans d'autres pays européens en fait
l'efficacité du moteur électrique
est-elle que même avec le mix électrique
qu'on a dans d'autres pays européens en
Allemagne en Allemagne
plus intéressant oui ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est si vous prenez une
voiture de même taille même puissance
même performance si vous en profitez
quand vous passez à l'électrique pour
doubler la taille de la voiture
évidemment un temps électrique là
l'avantage disparaît mais si vous êtes
dans la même catégorie on va dire là
vous avez un avantage alors c'est un
avantage mais c'est pas un avantage dans
lequel on divise les émissions par 10
c'est de quel ordre alors en France on
les divise par 3 ce qui est déjà très
bien ce qui est déjà très bien et on
pourrait les diviser par encore plus si
on fait en France l'essentiel des étapes
de fabrication de la batterie alors pour
faire une batterie qu'est-ce qu'il faut
il faut avoir une activité minière donc
il faut extraire du sol aujourd'hui du
lithium ça on pourrait le faire en
France du cobalt ça on en a pas en
France et du nickel ça on en a pas en
France métropolitaine il y en a en
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais il y en a pas en
France métropolitaine et après il faut
faire à partir de ça ce qu'on appelle
des principes actifs puis il faut
fabriquer les composants de la batterie
puis il faut faire la batterie elle-même
tout ça c'est aussi d'ailleurs l'objet
du déplacement Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui sera Dunkerque il y a ils
veulent développer la vallée de la
batterie alors ce qu'on va faire
aujourd'hui en France c'est la dernière
étape du processus donc c'est la
fabrication de la batterie elle-même
mais on va pas faire nécessairement les
cellules alors certains industriels le
prévoit d'autres non et on va pas faire
les principes actifs aujourd'hui il
faudra le faire plus tard il y a des
projets avec lesquels c'est prévu
mais aujourd'hui ça sera pas le cas et
ce qui va vraiment permettre
d'économiser du CO2 de fabrication c'est
quand on fera quand on ira le plus
possible à la montre si on voulait être
il faudrait qu'on est tout depuis la
mine on sauf que de l'intégralité du
processus de nickel et des mines de
combat c'est pas demain matin qu'on va
en avoir en France parce qu'il y a pas
la ressource en France métropolitaine
j'insiste mais par contre on peut faire
tout ce qui est à Laval par exemple les
Chinois dans un certain nombre pour un
certain nombre de métaux de spécialités
ils ont pas les mines chez eux mais par
contre c'est quand même eux qui
raffinent les métaux
d'accord donc ils importent le minerai
et ils font tout ce qu'il y a derrière
bon c'est à mon avis c'est ça la bonne
stratégie industrielle en France c'est
d'essayer de faire tout ça ça abaissera
encore les émissions de CO2 de
fabrication de la batterie et donc ça
rendra la voiture électrique encore plus
intéressante que la voiture à essence et
là on divisera encore plus que par 3 oui
en disant par plus que 3 Jean-Marc
Jean-Côme ici vous parliez des mines on
sait qu'il y a une mine de lithium qui
va ouvrir dans la ville mais il faut
bien voir par ailleurs que on a un
objectif en terme de décarbonation des
voitures à l'échelle mondiale donc à
l'échelle mondiale les voitures c'est à
peu près 6% des émissions gaz à effet de
serre de la planète d'accord pour donner
pour donner un ordre de grandeur ça veut
dire que si on veut Aya un peu plus d'un
milliard de voitures particulières sur
terre 1,2 milliards 1,3 milliards en
gros le vrai sujet c'est est-ce qu'on va
avoir la capacité industrielle à
électrifier toutes ces voitures en
quelques décennies et là on peut avoir
des doutes parce que il faut un certain
nombre de métaux en quantité très signif
notamment du cuivre et il y a une alerte
aujourd'hui sur la production de cuivre
à l'avenir il est possible que le pic de
production du cuivre ça soit pour les
années qui viennent
et donc la voiture électrique idéale
elle est en fait plus petite que la
voiture à essence est moins nombreuse
donc en fait électrique les voitures
c'est pas juste électrifier les voitures
à masse de voiture constante et à parc
de voitures qui font changer le modèle
de la voiture il faut il faut intégrer
ça dans une évolution plus large qui est
qu'il faut aussi qu'on fasse avec moins
de voitures et avec des voitures plus
petites avec moins de voitures des
voitures plus petites si je vous écoute
vous vous donneriez le bonus écologiste
à des voitures qui répondraient à ce
genre de critères si c'était moi je
mettrai trois conditions je mettrai une
condition de ressources à la personne
qui va acheter la voiture parce que une
personne comme moi par exemple qui a les
moyens de s'acheter une voiture
électrique qui a aucune raison qu'on me
donne un bonus il est sans condition de
ressources absolument et donc il va
notamment financer des voitures pour
quatre supérieurs qui sont des hybrides
donc des trucs qui devraient absolument
pas être subventionnés
électriques faut pas les subventionner
et 3
effectivement alors en fait sous con une
fois que j'ai dit sous condition de
masse j'ai presque 10 ou conditions de
puissance c'est pareil hein d'accord
donc être très attentif aussi aux
véhicules donc les petits véhicules et
il faudrait encore plus les
subventionsner quand il y a derrière la
casse d'un véhicule à essence donc quand
on est sûr que ça remplace un véhicule à
essence et pas que le véhicule à essence
est vendu pratiquement le volume si en
plus on supprime parce que en fait c'est
une voiture électrique vient se rajouter
au parc existant le bénéfice il existe
pas pour que le bénéfice existe il faut
que le véhicule électrique remplace une
voiture à pétrole du parc existant mais
justement sur ce point-là le fait
d'avoir annoncé que d'ici 2035 il n'y
aurait plus de ventes de voitures à
moteur thermique en Europe est-ce qu'on
n'a pas mis un peu la charrue avant les
boeufs et surtout est-ce qu'on n'a pas
créé
mécaniquement à un moment où on va
tellement produire de voiture pour
remplacer le parc existant que c'est un
moment finalement particulièrement
polluant alors
il y a toujours des émissions
supplémentaires quand vous êtes en
constitution de parc ça marche dans tous
les ça marche pour tout fait de manière
progressive là ça pourrait se faire de
manière accélérée en 2035 c'est pas
avoir une voiture à pétrole qui est
interdit c'est en acheter une ce qui est
très différent ce qui veut dire c'est
pour ceux qui en ont encore une
continueront à pouvoir la faire rouler
exactement donc la question elle est
celle de la vitesse de pénétration des
voitures électriques après cette date
dans le parc alors je vous avoue j'ai
pas en tête les derniers calculs qui ont
été faits sur le sujet mais c'est bien
ça la question c'est le remplacement
et l'autre question qui est posée c'est
celle que j'évoquais c'est à dire est-ce
qu'on va avoir la capacité industrielle
et les matières premières nécessaires
pour remplacer toutes les voitures qui
roulent aujourd'hui ou pas et si on n'a
pas cette matière première et si on n'a
pas cette capacité industrielle il y a
aussi un sujet de réorganisation du
système de transport et encore derrière
on va trouver un sujet de réorganisation
de l'urbanisme
parce que il y a tout il y a tout un tas
de trucs par exemple sur des bretelles
d'autoroute nouvelle qui sont qui sont
construites il y a la 69 vous vous dites
on devrait faire une pause là-dessus on
se trompe on devrait pas la construire
on devrait pas parce que en fait si on
l'a construit qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui on va favoriser des
habitudes de gens qui vont s'en servir
on va favoriser des implantations à côté
de cette nouvelle infrastructure
routière parce que c'est toujours comme
ça que ça se passe deux zones d'activité
etc de gens qui c'est normal je veux
dire le truc est là on s'en sert et
ensuite vous leur dit ah bah non
finalement on va devoir s'organiser
autrement et une fois que vous avez mis
votre peau vous laissiez votre votre
voiture au garage non et surtout les
camions
parce que il y a une chose dont on parle
pas quand on parle de l'électrification
des moyens de transport c'est des
marchandises
est-ce que ça doit être la cible je sais
pas de quoi il parle donc vous avez des
normes environnementales il y en a des
centaines il y en a des milliers donc je
sais pas de quoi ils parlent est-ce
qu'on peut se dire qu'il y en a trop je
ne sais pas
donc la bonne question c'est de quoi
parle-t-il je ne sais pas mais est-ce
que est-ce que les normes sont
nécessaires ou est-ce qu'effectivement
évidemment quels sont nécessaires pas je
vais prendre un exemple qui est le
bâtiment
s'il y avait pas de crises du bâtiment
oui mais s'il y avait pas dans le
bâtiment des normes sur la manière de
construire bah vous sauriez pas si votre
bâtiment va résister aux inondations à
la éventuellement au tremblement de
terre dans les zones sismiques etc donc
évidemment qu'il faut des normes c'est
absolument indispensable s'il y avait
pas une norme sur le filetage des vis
par exemple un truc tout con et bien les
différents fabricants de vie et de
boulon feraient des filetages qui se
correspondent pas nécessairement donc la
norme c'est quelque chose qui est non
mais je suis trop impatiente
que des que des vies et des voitures
électriques c'est tout con mais donc en
fait la norme est absolument
indispensable dans un système industriel
puisqu'on en est au logement cette
majeure que traverse la France avec une
catastrophe à venir peu de réponses
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
mais une question également qui est
celle de la maison individuelle alors la
ministre du Logement précédentes
Emmanuel wargon avait mis les pieds dans
le plat ça lui avait été énormément
reproché en disant que peut-être que le
modèle de la maison individuelle était
daté qu'est-ce que vous répondez
là-dessus Jean-Marc jeancovici c'est
aujourd'hui l'un des problèmes c'est
qu'il y a moins de construction et comme
il y a moins de construction il y a
aussi une tension sur le monde de
l'immobilier et sur le monde du logement
qui est extrêmement lourde est-ce qu'il
faut construire plus ou est-ce qu'en
effet il faut se dire c'est plus le
modèle il y a quelques années avant le
monde sans fin j'avais écrit un bouquin
dans lequel un des chapitres s'appelait
mettre les villes à la campagne c'est
fait alors quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé avec l'abondance énergétique avant
l'abondance énergétique qu'est-ce qui se
passait vous aviez soit des gens qui
habitaient à la campagne dans des
maisons donc l'habitat rurale standard
c'était pas des immeubles c'était des
maisons mais à ce moment ils avaient une
activité qui demandait très peu de
transport le déplacement quotidien de
l'agriculteur ou du paysan c'était chez
lui jusqu'à son champ le champ était pas
loin etc et il y avait donc en fait on
avait un modèle entre travail et habitat
ça flottait parce que vous aviez pas
besoin de vous déplacer à partir de
votre logement pour aller loin bon et
les gens qui étaient en ville ils
étaient dans des endroits où il pouvait
tout faire à pied c'est pour ça que les
coeurs de vie l'historique en Europe
sont tous des cœur de ville très denses
concentrés où on peut tout faire à pied
si vous habitez dans Paris vous pouvez
quasiment tout faire à pied ça pose pas
de problème et dans n'importe quelle
ville ancienne vous pouvez faire ça avec
l'énergie abondante on s'est mis à avoir
hors des villes des gens qui ont une
activité de type urbain des emplois de
service enfin des emplois industriels et
des emplois de service et par ailleurs
qui ont besoin d'une voiture du coup
pour assurer une mobilité loin de leur
domicile puisqu'ils sont plus
agriculteurs et ils ont
plus on rajoute aujourd'hui des zones
pavillonnaires plus on rajoute des gens
qui sont dépendants de la voiture or on
vient de se dire que la dépendance à la
voiture c'est quelque chose qui n'est
peut-être pas garanti pour l'éternité
c'est à dire qu'il va peut-être pas y
avoir les moyens matériels de conserver
les 40 millions de véhicules
particuliers qu'on a en France alors
l'absence de ces moyennes matériels ça
se traduira par des pénuries de
l'inflation etc c'est ce genre de truc
qui qui va matérialiser le ou des
interdictions mais c'est comme ça que ça
va se manifester du coup est-ce que
c'est très raisonnable aujourd'hui de
continuer à mettre des gens dans des
zones où ils se disent à court terme là
je vais être très bien mais sauf que
dans cinq ans dans 10 ans dans 20 ans
est-ce qu'il y a même qui sont pénalisés
avec le bien de leur transport
individuel s'il y a une impossibilité
physique d'assurer le déplacement d'une
partie des gens qui habitent dans ces
zones c'est pas complètement illégitime
aujourd'hui de dire c'est peut-être pas
une bonne idée de continuer à les
augmenter ces zones donc du coup la
bonne question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait mais de partir de l'idée mais
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour la guitare qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pour le logement qui est en grave
crise aujourd'hui alors il y a deux
choses distinctes d'abord il faut savoir
parce que ça vient quand même
artificialiser et construire pour des
occupations qui sont qui sont
ponctuelles et qui nécessitent un
transport et qui soit hors des zones par
ailleurs d'activité économiques voilà on
a également un sujet sur la déprise d'un
certain nombre de villes donc c'est quoi
la déprise vous avez un certain nombre
de villes moyennes dans lesquels vous
avez de moins en moins de gens qui
habitent vous avez le taux de vacances
des logements qui augmentent et donc les
gens qui vaut mieux réintégrer dans tous
les dieux
retraités veulent faire construire en
Bretagne et sur la Côte d'Azur pendant
que à Valenciennes ou à Arras vous avez
des gens qui vous avez des logements
vides donc vous avez un sujet aussi
d'aménagement du territoire alors
aménager le territoire ça porte un
vilain nom et ça s'appelle la
planification mais ça veut dire que il
faut essayer par exemple de faire les
nouvelles usines de batterie ou d'autres
dans des endroits où il y a plein de
logements vacants histoire de recréer
histoire de recréer de l'activité alors
je connais pas le taux de vacances des
logements à Dunkerque mais histoire de
recréer de l'activité
il faut donc recréer de l'activité
idéalement dans des endroits où il y a
déjà des logements vides donc en fait
aujourd'hui ce qu'on ne sait pas faire
parce que l'abondance énergétique nous a
rendu la vie facile et donc on a pas eu
besoin de se creuser la cervelle c'est
refaire des plans un peu larges mailles
en juxtaposant le sujet des transports
le sujet des logements le sujet de
l'activité le sujet de l'agriculture et
cetera et à comprendre comment est-ce
que tout ça continue à flotter dans un
monde dans lequel les flux physiques
seront moins faciles à créer moins
faciles à créer et d'ailleurs vous le
dites par nécessité c'est à dire que oui
vous faites partie de ceux qui depuis
longtemps disent c'est même pas juste
parce que je voudrais moins polluer ou
être moins écolo c'est parce que
simplement mécaniquement on va avoir des
ressources en euros qui ne sont pas
illimitées et donc à un moment ou un
autre faudra s'arrêter alors on a déjà
si je prends l'exemple des combustibles
fossiles là l'Europe étant décrue de
consommation de charbon subit depuis le
milieu des années 50 parce que ça fait
deux siècles qu'on tape dans les mines
de charbon c'est le pic de production du
charbon en Grande-Bretagne c'était 1914
dire ça fait longtemps donc on est en
décrue sur le charbon oui et du coup
comme le charbon est compliqué à
transporter à leurs échelle on consomme
de moins en moins de charbon ça date
d'avant le climat on est en décrue
pétrolière subit depuis 2008 et ça ça
c'est lié au pic de production du
pétrole conventionnel donc tout ce qui
est pas les sables bitumineux du Canada
et le pétrole de schiste américain
depuis 2008 en Europe également et on
est en décrus subit de
l'approvisionnement gazier depuis le pic
de production de la mer du Nord qui a
passé son pic en 2005 parce que le gaz
demande des tuyaux ou des métiers c'est
plus compliqué à transporter que le
pétrole et donc on consomme également de
moins en moins de gaz en Europe depuis
cette époque tout ça n'a rien à voir
avec le climat tout ça est juste lié à
la géologie et au fait que on subit ces
décrus un mot quand même du climat
justement
c'est une bonne affaire pour le CO2 mais
en attendant c'est juste pour dire que
les limites physiques ça existe l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie à il y a
maintenant un an à peu près émis une
alerte alors ils l'ont émis à la manière
de l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
c'est-à-dire c'est une note de bas de
page 136 d'un rapport
que pour les mines de cuivre
actuellement en production ou en
développement c'est-à-dire que les
infrastructures de production sont en
cours de construction le pic de
production et pour les années qui
viennent bon donc vous voyez les limites
physiques ça existe et les limites
physiques c'est aussi l'eau je voudrais
quand même prendre un mot Jean-Marc
Jacob ici cette sécheresse extrême des
départements qui se trouvent déjà en
crise de sécheresse avec des habitants
qui sont quasi rationnés est-ce que ça
va s'installer et quelle est la réponse
qu'il faut apporter ça s'installe déjà
en France sur les deux dernières années
il n'y a eu que trois ou quatre mois de
mémoire où les précipitations ont été
supérieurs à la normale tout le reste du
temps elles ont été inférieures à la
normale et évidemment l'hiver dernier en
particulier a été très sec heureusement
qu'il pleut en ce moment présentateur
météo disait tout à l'heure à moi je
voudrais qu'on arrête d'utiliser
l'expression beau temps quand il y a du
soleil en fait aujourd'hui le beau temps
c'est quand il pleut alors effectivement
on chene un peu parce qu'on sort les
parapluies mais il vaut mieux sortir les
parapluies et avoir de quoi manger
plutôt que de pas avoir de parapluie et
c'est pas moi
quand même
la fin de de la maison individuelle pas
de résidence secondaire reprendre ses
pattes pour marcher et se réjouir de la
pluie c'est très bien de reprendre ses
pattes pour marcher je vous assure ça
fait faire un peu d'exercice ça
déstresse c'est parfait c'est à la
marche c'est une excellente chose
du monde et même qui paye très cher pour
mais mais cela dit Jean-Marc Jancovici
sur cette histoire de sécheresse est-ce
qu'il faut s'y habituer est-ce qu'il
faut changer nos habitudes de
consommation malheureusement oui pour ce
que parce que ça fait longtemps qu'on
sait avec les simulations climatiques
que dans le cadre du réchauffement en
cours le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen va sécher donc il y a pas
que le sud de la France qui s'assèche ce
qui se passe en Espagne en ce moment et
parti est encore plus aigu que ce qui se
passe en France c'est pareil ça fait
trois ans qu'ils ont des précipitations
déficitaires ils abordent le printemps
et l'été avec des réservoirs qui sont
remplis au quart de leur capacité quand
vous allez encore plus au sud au Maroc
l'année dernière il y a eu une perte de
la récolte en céréales extrêmement
marquée là en ce moment la situation
également est extrêmement critique la
sécheresse a joué un rôle direct dans le
déclenchement du printemps arabe donc
c'est quelque chose malheureusement
auquel il va falloir s'habituer les
rizières de la plaine du pot sont
également à un niveau historiquement bas
et ce n'est malheureusement que le début
alors je vais vous faire encore moins
rêver tant mieux pour votre mari mais
malheureusement il va falloir s'y
habituer parce que encore une fois dans
le cadre de l'évolution climatique en
cours les précipitations du pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen vont baisser et les
sols vont s'asser en gros on va perdre
10% d'humidité des sols par degré de
réchauffement global ce n'est donc que
le début et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler Jean-Marc Jancovici merci en
tout cas d'être venu ce matin vous êtes
ingénieur et je citais votre livre il
s'appelle le monde sans